[Music]
foreign
Butler and Kaya Gerber enjoying their
poolside vacay yeah it's amazing yeah
the couple was spotted packing on the
PDA during their Mexico getaway and
looks like Austin's taking on the role
of the ultimate Instagram boyfriend
[Music]
check out the actor helping his lady
love get the picture-perfect shot I'm
not complaining to love birds ring in
the New Year while on vacation with
Kaya's family they've been soaking up to
sun with her famous mom Cindy Crawford
dad Randy Gerber and brother Presley as
your kid gets older as you know you
really it does get better and better
because even though you might miss the
little snuggly thing you see them become
like this person that is just like their
own creature and you're like in awe
Austin and Kaya first barked romance
rumors back in December 2021 at the time
A source told ET the two were seeing
each other adding quote they're getting
to know each other better and having a
lot of fun hanging out that was really
special
the bear made things red carpet official
last year at the Met Gala looking
totally smitten with each other and it
was also date night for the duo at the
world premiere of Austin's film Elvis at
the 2022 Cannes Film Festival
[Applause]
Elvis is so loved and so iconic you feel
you feel responsibility playing any
human that has actually lived but with
him it's it's like it's it's a weight
like I never felt before okay and
there's a responsibility to his family
and also putting his story into context
like that was a big thing there's so
many misconceptions about him there's so
many ideas of him so I felt such a
responsibility to bring the humanity
right since then Austin and Kaya have
mainly stayed out of the spotlight but
with award season around the corner fans
can't wait to see this couple shine on
the red carpet again
[Music]